here's the reality the roster that was
inherited by adam gase and joe douglas
needed a ton
of heavy lifting they they were built
from the outside in they needed to be
built from the inside out that's what
joe douglas is doing and christopher
johnson who's running the team while his
brother woody serves as the u.s
ambassador to uk
christopher johnson has given adam gase
a vote of confidence
woody johnson still owns the team and
there's a point where and this is my my
fear
for gays and and maybe to a lesser
extent douglas although he's got a
six-year contract i don't think he's
going anywhere but at some point you
just feel like you need to do something
it's gotten to the point where it's so
bad you need to do something the reports
last week of players who say we're not
practicing very hard
at some point someone's gonna feel
compelled to do something
just to flip the narrative you're
talking about a team that's in new york
city you've got a thursday night game
coming up against the denver broncos the
ratings locally for the jets in new york
have not been good even though the fans
aren't there to not show up or to show
up with bags on their heads
there's a point where
even if you want to stick with the plan
even if you believe that if you keep
gates and douglas together for the next
two three four years you're eventually
going to have a winner
you still have a business that is driven
by people wanting to watch your games on
tv even if they can't show up and see
them in person
and there's only so much of that they're
going to take before you just have to
say we're just out of time yeah and i i
fear
that that point may be coming where they
just have to throw their hands up in the
air and say we we we just we can't we
can't we we can't function anymore
given the fact that we're getting the
crap i almost said a different word
kicked out of us each and every week if
you're not getting the crap kicked out
of you each and every week it's
different but to not be competitive at
all against a 49ers team that is ravaged
by injuries to not be competitive at all
against the cults there's a point where
it becomes inexcusable and there's a
point where the fans just are going to
turn off the tv they're not even going
to turn it on they're not even going to
bother they're going to go about their
lives and they're just going to pretend
the jets don't exist and that's the
worst that can happen when you're a
professional football team that relies
upon people giving a crap about your
product no you're exactly right and you
know and even to further what you're
saying i mean they weren't competitive
in week one against the buffalo bills
either they're the worst team in
football and yeah i'm a little bit of a
defender of adam gates because of what
you started to say there i mean
the the team that was handed over to him
and joe douglas is crap i don't know any
way to say it crap the worst built
football team in the nfl the worst i
don't think it's even close really so
joe douglas obviously like you said he's
safe he's in it for the long haul
six-year deal he's gonna be there at
least for the next three to four for
sure with that type of deal but then
adam gase yeah i worry about him i i
understand it it doesn't look good and
then when you're supposed to be an
offensive mind and there's no
offensive excitement to kind of keep you
know tease the fans with or anything
like that
that's when you're going to hear it and
then it's okay yeah you got a top five
quarterback who doesn't seem to be
delivering yeah it's not on sam donald
anybody out there that's a jets fan or
anything like that he's not the problem
i mean the problem with the new york
jets the biggest issue they have right
here is this mike
there
they have no receivers
none
i mean last week
they had a they had a
how to make chris hokan chris hogan the
focal point of their offense like the
go-to number one receiver chris hogan's
from my hometown i love him to death at
this point of this career he should not
be the number one target for any offense
and i don't mean that to be
disrespectful yesterday braxton barrios
he's the go-to guy i mean who what do
they expect running backs are old
there's nothing special there offensive
lines getting better it's young it's a
work in progress defense there's not one
household name on the whole defense
nobody you can look at
so yeah gates it's not exciting he needs
to do more you're right he's in trouble
but i don't know really what's expected
to be done with the players they have on
the field right now
and see that's the thing can you hold
this together long enough to get enough
players to make the team better can you
get the fans to accept that this is a
multi-year build you still have to be
somewhat competitive with the guys you
have you cannot treat you know this is
the flip side of the vikings scholarship
year it's like a red shirt year for the
jets you can't treat it like a red shirt
year you don't have the security you
don't have the equity that the vikings
have of going to the playoffs every
other year and the not too
distant memory of the minneapolis
miracle to placate the fans right for
the jets what is there what is there no
i know the past 25 30 50 years for the
jets right they went to an afc
championship game a couple of times
whoopty freaking do yeah that's it for
the last 50 years so you know at some
point and that's the thing
what do they say love and hate are very
similar for their intensity apathy is
the thing that you want to avoid and
apathy is i think what jets fans are
quickly settling into
and uh and and that's not good for
anybody that's as as as they said about
the kenny rogers roasters it's not going
to be good for business that's not going
to be good for anybody and and and you
know yeah i feel like and look this
isn't political at all depending upon
the outcome of the election woody
johnson may be back
and he may be back soon and i think when
woody comes back he's probably going to
tell everybody get the hell out and
whatever check he's got to write to buy
out joe douglas adam gase his own
brother whatever he's got to do
everybody get the hell out we're going
to start over we're bringing back rex
ryan i'm kidding about that well yeah i
mean i i mean no yeah i i i think you
are kidding and let's hope we are you
know
but i know i know well he had a great
run
but it ended up don't they don't have to
go back there they don't need to go back
there okay they were good they were good
they were good they were all seven years
ago okay that's i don't care now all
right so
but but
you know rex would take that job back
again in a heartbeat he would happily be
the new billy martin fire me again and
bring me back oh well yeah he won't like
it and he's great in new york i mean you
know jets fans the way he interacts with
the media everything it it is a great
marriage i'm not trying to like you know
say anything and the billy martin
experience but if this is the the ground
is fertile for some i'm telling you
hey this is just pull it out of the air
or somewhere else i'm just telling you
there's something fascinating about the
possibility of rex coming back i mean
this is a team right now that is
lifeless well there's no hope that's
what i want to say there's nothing to
give a crap about no no you know so it's
all i know is this woody's coming home
potentially soon and that could be the
best news for jets fans because i think
he's going to tell everybody
we got we got to press the reset button
and start well they give no hope i think
that's what you're saying like we saw
the 49ers be 3 and 13 and 6 and 10 or
whatever like early on in the shanahan
era but we saw there and we went man but
every week the game was close and the
offense was exciting and you went all
right there's something to latch on
there too right then even last year you
know like yeah the arizona cardinals
they weren't great right
but we saw things that made us go oh
wait there's there's a future here this
damn quarterback and this offense and
the way it works i can kind of see it
starts to make sense
you know there's hope
right now i don't think any jet fan can
look at the jets and see vision where
it's going excitement
there's really no part of the football
team to be excited about and i think
that's what bothers them more than
anything at least my jet friends
and i'm sorry but i just don't think
it's going to be turning around anytime
soon there sorry matt casey producer
sorry
we got to take a break but 10 more
seconds real quickly
chris you and i both think matt adam
gates got a raw deal in miami
and he got thrown into a bad situation
with the jets
and uh it's unfortunate but sometimes
you just get to a point where
whatever the reason whatever the cause
whatever the story's behind it you just
got to hit the big red button and start
over again i feel like they're teetering
close to that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports